they were asking the right questions
we can stop as much as you want by the
way
Game of Thrones flips my whole world on
its head I sometimes worry that I'm like
alienated because it will happen when I
was so young and like literally from the
age of 12 I've been like set for life
I had a traumatic relationship with my
dad and ever since I can remember like
I've really struggled sleeping it had
like met its like Peak and I was at
school I was taken by a teacher to the
staff room she was saying like what's
happened
I think a lot of the traumatic things
that were happening I didn't realize
that they were wrong I would look around
at other kids and be like where does the
joy when does that come for me
when you were 22 you talked about issues
with substance abuse yeah I would just
had that sense of impending doom and I
didn't know how to make it go away
[Music]
I'm gonna come and give you a hug
[Music]
before this conversation starts I've got
a favor to ask from you 74 of people
that watch this podcast frequently
haven't yet hit the Subscribe button and
nine percent of people haven't yet hit
the Bell to turn notifications on the
bigger this platform gets the bigger the
guests get so if you could do me one
favor if you've ever enjoyed this
podcast please hit the Subscribe button
and turn notifications on without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
[Music]
foreign
what do I need to understand who you are
now what do I need to know about
that part of your life
um well I as like a young child before
the age of like eight
um had
quite a traumatic like relationship with
my dad and I don't really want to go
into it too much because it affects my
siblings and my whole family
um but like that really consumed a lot
of my childhood
um
ever since I can remember like I've
really struggled sleeping and I think a
lot of the traumatic things that were
happening I didn't realize that they
were wrong but I knew that like I would
look around at other kids and be like
why
why like why don't they seem to
understand this like pain or dread or
fear like
like you know what where does the joy
like when does that come for me like I
you know I kind of always felt like a
felt things very deeply
um in comparison to other people and so
when that sort of period of my life
ended
um I imagined that like you know
everything is just like up from here
like everything's perfect now
um all those things that I was concerned
about were actually wrong and like now
I'm sort of free
um
yeah and then you know at different
stages in life you realize that
there's never like an end destination
for that freedom um and it's
yeah it kind of comes from within I
guess like when are you going to
let yourself be free from
from the pain but yeah that really
consumed a lot of my childhood that was
sort of like what I was identified as
you know what I identified myself as for
a long time and then
you know everything changed and I sort
of became this like
you know character who
uh who wouldn't let anything bad happen
to her or anyone around her and
yeah I guess like maybe there is some
sort of like connection between those
two things
your mother left your father yeah before
I was born actually well no I guess
she
escaped when I was about four months old
so
it was you know bad before that and then
uh yeah have you spoken about this
before no
I don't know I like you I'm sorry I feel
like this is an um
it's something that I've been like
learning a lot about recently and I feel
like I can speak about it now yeah
um does it has it taken you time to like
to can I ask the question about have you
spoken about it before because
um
I think at like 25 years old there was
like really foundational things I
learned about myself that that I only
learn I mean you know sometimes you read
something or you hear something and you
go [ __ ] that explains this thing
so my question there was just like did
it take you time to connect those dots
yeah definitely
I think that people sort of talk about
like rewiring people on your podcast
actually speak about rewiring your brain
but that first in order to do that you
have to recognize when your your brain
is doing a pattern that you want to
rewire and quite often like it's already
triggered so many things and like you're
in a bad mood and you have no idea why
and it's hard to kind of like Trace back
from that point so like that awareness
um
and like finding that kind of for me had
to come first like when it really
started to I don't know when I really
started to understand it
it was like capturing those minutes
where I was like why does that make me
feel really uncertain or
angry or like make me wanna like
shout at someone like what what is that
and then you can start to go like
work your way back you know so you were
seeing like social triggers or
situations where you were you know I saw
you I saw you said when you spoke to
Lewis house you said I've always been
quite an anxious person yeah and I
really reflect on that because I you
know I'm not an expert in anxiety I've
been anxious myself I've been an anxious
person at times myself but um
I I've always wondered for many years if
we're we're born that way or if if we're
predisposed or if something happens and
then we become anxious
have you
thinking about how you saw sort of
social triggers have you connected any
dots regarding being an anxious person
as you call it to those early years
as you've grown up now
um
yeah
I guess I think like a lot of that
anxiety
as I started to sort of recognize it it
came from like not really being myself
and like then feeling anxious about the
way that you're being perceived or
whatever but knowing that you're not
really being honest and that will of
course make you very anxious because if
you have no idea who you're projecting
then you really have no idea how other
people are going to hear it because you
don't even know how you mean it and you
know that sort of like facade of like
I don't know whoever you know whoever I
thought was like capable of like getting
through interviews or social like
settings or whatever
um
and I think that like struggle with
identity and like the big questions of
like who am I I think that everyone
struggles with that
um but I think that like you know
there's a period of your childhood
um where
you know certain situations
can really stunt
um like
or just Ulta forever like who you are
going to become
um
and that's not to say that you can't
also just like become a very peaceful
and uh
you know content and fulfilled person
um but like that sort of Basic Instinct
of like what do I what brings me joy you
know you've kind of second guessed that
a lot as a kid and you're not known
you know whether to trust what you
really think or feel or you know
whatever sort of like mental
manipulation
um and that can yeah really have like
lasting effects so
yeah kind of like discovering that and
being like yes I struggle with you know
my identity and knowing who I am so that
brings me anxiety because I don't know
who to be in a social situation
um but then also sort of going back back
far enough that you're like oh
I don't know if that person really
exists anymore and that's okay because I
can find
you know something
um
yeah you know find like a good
version of myself
um but yeah I don't know how do you what
do you think about that
um about which part well I guess
um like it feels like a lot of people
are trying to retreat to like being a
child and like the things that brought
you Joy and like who you are at your
core and who you are when no one's
looking and
um
uh but you know can can that that part
of you be so damaged from a very a young
age that
that you could be searching for
something that
um
you know is just for you to make up
that's a really interesting question
when I've never even pondered before
um I was thinking about in fact Lewis
Howes and I think shortly after you had
a conversation with him
it would have been because I know the
timeline he I think he opened up for the
first time it's so funny because
when I rewatched your conversation with
Lewis
you start sharing things that were
difficult in your early years you don't
share anything like this with him and
then he says to you he's quite stoic and
he goes yeah I went through things like
that as well you're aware of what he
yeah yeah I am now see he went through
um they're pretty you know horrific uh
child abuse at a young age from I
believe a babysitter if I'm correct that
was looking after him
I had sexually abused him and he talks
my reference is only him talking about
how he feels he has to go back and for
like forgive
himself
the child that he was and heal himself
heal the child yeah yeah so he has I
don't know if you know but he has his
face
at that age on his wallpaper of his
phone and with his therapist he's worked
through healing that young version of
himself and then moving on to the next
to the teenage years and so do I do I do
I know if we can um if that child that
we're seeking
still exists in there I mean my very
naive assumption would be that they do
yeah
um are they are they still going to be
childlike
I don't know
there's something
quite naive about it being childlike
which may be wisdom
makes irreversible but
when you when you talk about Joy you
talk about struggling to feel Joy at a
young age
what is that how do I how do I how do I
understand those words
I think like
you know when you watch
kids play
um
and like there's struggles and there's
tiffs and there's like whatever but
there's like
just like complete inhibition right and
it's just like running or it's like
going on the slide or it's like
I felt like I would often stop in a
situation like that I'd be doing
something and then I would just stop and
be like something awful is going to
happen
and just like
I
couldn't
continue
um
tissue yeah maybe Jack could you grab a
tissue please
we can stop as much as you want by the
way we don't have to carry on
it's a great thing for podcasting yeah
yeah maybe I'll hide them around the
other side I could put them just like
here cool is that that's off camera yeah
it's all good
um
yeah I would just
um
had that sense of impending doom and I
didn't know how to make it go away
um
and I had to like
great memories I don't even know it's
hard to remember a lot of them a lot of
those times that I felt very free I was
actually on my own
um
but I would never have like thought I
was like an introverted person like I
always would have thought that I was
quite extroverted because
um I'd perform a lot of people you know
um
but yeah I yeah I struggled I yeah I
struggled with that when I was a kid
um
and just thought like
how do I stop feeling like this and just
feel like
everything's okay you know but at that
age I'm guessing you didn't know why you
felt like that so knowing how to to go
about
yeah healing from it is is an impossible
task right it's good point about you
can't solve for something that you
you're not aware of yeah
going like nothing's wrong like nothing
is wrong everything's the way that it's
supposed to be
but it wasn't but I did I just would
tell myself that like what is wrong with
you like
was there an age when you found found
out
because I kind of asked this question
earlier but was there any was there a
moment where you found out what was
wrong yeah
when I was about eight
um
I
was quite like a complex like string of
events that happened
but basically it had like met its like
Peak and I was at school
and I guess I was well I mean obviously
I was really struggling
um
and I don't really know what happened
but I was taken by a teacher to the
staff room and
um
she was saying like what's wrong you
know like what's happened
have you are you hungry well and she
said I don't know
yeah you're hungry I said yeah she said
did you eat breakfast and I said no and
she said oh why not and I said we just
didn't have any breakfast and you know
and then she says well you know do you
normally have breakfast and he's not
really and so you know the sort of they
were asking the right questions
okay
so you can get them
I'm gonna come and give you I feel
really confounded
okay yeah
yeah
no I I do think it's important because
I had so many people who loved and cared
about me so much but I'd never been
asked the right questions where I could
really say
what was wrong
um
and
um my mum came to school and picked me
up and
um my siblings were also at secondary
school at the time and they
um some of them was were with mum and
one was not and they were dead still and
yeah
um and it was the first time that like
it was all of the doors were sort of
open and all of these things that we
were experiencing were like out on the
table and
it was really really hard because I
still wanted to fight and say no like
these things aren't bad like
you're trying to take me away from my
dad and that's wrong you know like
um because I was like indoctrinated in a
way like you know
um
I think that's why I'm obsessed with
Cults because I'm like I get it I get it
I was in a child cult against my mother
um yeah so I really was sort of fighting
it for for at the beginning but but
basically like my whole
world like
flips on its head and even though all
these things that I'd was feeling I
thought oh my God I'm so glad I don't
have to see my dad anymore
uh it still was like against everything
that I had ever
knew to be true you know
I don't know if I'm being too cryptic no
I don't think I am I don't think you are
you can be as cryptic as you wanna
yeah yeah I understand what you're
saying and that's the that's one that I
need to to get the context um and you
can just talk as come whatever you about
whatever you want to talk about in terms
of what makes you comfortable I don't
know I don't know where your line is
yeah
you need that
um
when I watch cult documentaries there's
a lot of um manipulation that goes on in
these documentaries there's a lot of
fear that causes silence
um
and that's usually why
people find it that's often why people
find it difficult to leave those
situations and then when they do have
these like I always observe this like
conflicting array of emotions like they
have this love for this person but at
the same time
as you've you've described it once out
of that situation there's somewhat are
probably you know a spirit spiritually
free and happy to be gone so that that
conflict of emotions always fascinated
me how two truths can almost exist in
the same place
you can feel
you know so
um liberated and free and at the same
time just like that impending doom is
kind of still there where
yeah
it's like all your problems don't just
sort of like go away you know
um
yeah you still
like care a lot about that person or you
still sort of understand
you know the pain or whatever that led
to those very very poor decisions
as you sit here today 25 years old how
do you feel about
your father
well to be honest with you
I've been thinking about this a lot
um
and
like I've been trying to do this thing
where I stopped taking things personally
and like not just like you know when
someone's had a bad day and they like
push in front of you in the queue but
like the big things in life like what if
I said that it was not like it wasn't
because of me that that happened
like
it it if it if I wasn't there it would
have been something someone else like
it's not
um
yeah it wasn't like because
there's something wrong with me that
like these bad things happened when I
was a child
is that a thought you had
yeah yeah yeah
I felt like there was something
inherently wrong with me or us because
like we did lots of things wrong all the
time which is like why you know
you you know you'd be mistreated or
whatever because you're like oh like we
really need to be better at this because
we keep doing things wrong and we keep
getting in trouble type thing
um but then I was like well you know
like and especially well because it was
someone you know my a parent and I felt
like oh they're supposed to like like
you and so
you know but then I was like well what
if like there's just like no connection
between like me being
you know his daughter and like it could
have been like literally anyone like
experiencing
that pain and it would like still be the
same and then I just kind of could
separate myself from it a little bit and
I could start to sort of reflect on him
as a person and be like what happens
that you get so stuck in your mind that
you can just like
you know permanently like mistreat
people
um
you know what
children
children
like your own children
but but you know
taking that step back and seeing it like
more objectively
kind of like makes me quite interested
in in the guy I don't know him at all
um and I'm like
what happened to you when you were a kid
like
who are your parents
is this something that you were always
like when you were a kid did you like
pull the legs off bugs or like
you know did this did you learn this
like you know these are all the
questions that I would ask yeah yeah and
so that's kind of like how I feel about
them now where I'm just like what if
like he would make a fascinating
documentary and it's like nice to to
like
you know not feel the the personal pain
of that anymore and actually just think
like
you know
I don't know if any of the answers to
that will like help me in my journey
um but it is sort of like a nicer way to
think of him than
you know as like someone who doesn't
love me or like me or like whatever
you know he talked about that feeling
that you were to blame for
outcomes in your life that might well
especially as a relationship early as
that weren't you weren't to blame for
um were there symptoms of that as you
grew up this kind of the feeling that
you know
um when things happen it was because you
did something wrong or you were you were
to blame for things did you feel that as
an adult in your teenage years at all
yeah definitely I think that like I
really
um
wanted to control a lot of things that
you just can't control because
like
if I don't then if I'm not worrying or
thinking about this or like wanting to
control this then like it's all going to
fall down and like then I'll blame
myself and it'll be like a you know
something that I could have done better
or should have done differently
um
yeah I feel like
I guess it was more just like trying to
control like the uncontrollable and that
then leading to like another way that I
could like
beat myself down you know
it's interesting because I've seen so
many other interviews you've done and
without knowing that early context a lot
of those a lot of the things I was
hearing didn't make sense yeah yeah not
that you know it makes sense is maybe an
interesting use of words but
um it always felt like there was a part
of your story that was
Untold
yeah
it you know I think when I was like 12
and I'd done a bit of Game of Thrones
and was doing interviews and like the
first interviews that I'd ever done
I remember people sort of being like but
you're so young like how do you
protect like how do you show this pain
like you've just seen like the death of
your father or like how do you know that
like how no how do you
act that sort of like Fury and I just
like in my head was like that's a really
stupid question because I've known how
that feels but like you know I it's like
I don't know something nice to just like
leave in the past I guess but
it's it's hugely influenced like
everything that I do as an actor like I
get to access all of that confusion and
pain
in my job and I get to like really feel
it in like every
fiber of my being but there's no like
consequence and there's no like you're
not really shouting at anyone or hurting
someone or it's like it's all pretend
but like the emotion is is real and like
just being able to like let that out is
something that I didn't do for a long
time and so it's like it just all sort
of came to the surface and
I guess like holding you know
the early part of my story like to
myself is also just because I haven't
really understood it the way that I have
now and and I'm sure I'll understand it
you know far better in the future but
I feel
um I feel like now there's like some
sort of closure to it where the journey
might help other people whereas before
it was just like pain pain pain pain
and no like conclusion right right no
like okay we're through the other side
yeah it was just like other problems
that come from like the same problem
problems yeah
um
but yeah I mean it's like you know
going into that audition to play Arya
Stark I was sort of surrounded by girls
that like were joyous and like were
free and like
like they were kids there were kids who
were happy and
um you know
had you know had whatever they had
um
and I thought wow I really
um you know here we go again like gonna
be a disappointment but you know for
that
moment actually that was that was what
they needed and so that was sort of like
a
moment in my life where I was like huh
maybe this thing isn't all bad maybe
there can be something like beautiful
that comes from
you know this this part of myself that I
find like
um
unnatural like or like just different to
to other kids
here we go again I'm going to be a
disappointment
oh yeah
yeah
what do you mean by that
so when you when you got the role you
presumed that you were going to let
people down yeah yeah no
I just like going into the room I meant
like okay oh no I'm not gonna be what
they're looking for but I I did end up
being what they were looking for but
like you know I just um
yeah yeah yeah of course
um
yeah
I don't know like did you did you like
always feel ever feel like disappointing
yeah
yeah of course yeah there's been moments
in my life where I've definitely feel
like I've let myself down and other
people down and it's not a good feeling
to to sit with but I think I've tried to
channel it into
um
into making myself I actually went for
an audition at 14 years old to do the
junior Apprentice you know The
Apprentice the TV show so they launched
the junior apprentice and I went for the
first audition got through to the final
20 and then I got long story but I got
this email from the BBC saying that
someone had leaked the press that I was
going on the show so they said this is
jeopardized your chances of going on the
show and I don't come from a family
where we had much so going back to
Plymouth and telling everyone you know
like all my friends oh he's going to
London and going back and saying like
they've just called me and told me I'm
not on the show was was devastating for
a long time lots of tears I felt like a
disappointment of that phase in my life
um and several times subsequently but
um I I think I've always been somewhat
optimistic going into situations
I generally feel like I've got nothing
to lose
um
[Music]
and I think maybe that's a bit of a
privilege to be honest I think mindset
privilege is a real thing just like
perspective privilege something we don't
talk about enough and
um had I been in an early situation
where someone was continually
telling me the things that I was were
doing were wrong or not good enough or
whatever I can quite easily see how I
would anticipate that feedback going
into anything where
um feedback was going to be given
and it's actually pretty remarkable I
mean
you know because those early experiences
you would assume would smash someone's
like self-esteem pretty severely and and
make them kind of retreat into safe
places one of the safest places is where
we don't get feedback and someone
doesn't shout at us or you know but that
that first this is your first audition
right Game of Thrones yeah or one of I I
had an audition before that which I also
was very excited about and then didn't
get so that was like my first like okay
you know professional rejection but
you're still putting yourself out there
in situations where you could be
rejected yeah definitely and I think it
was because I the only time that I
really felt that joy that I saw in other
people was when I was like dancing or
performing and there was this feeling
that I would get that I was like this is
like
I feel like human you know
um and so I was like I've just got to do
anything I can to like do this forever
and so from a very young age I was like
I want to go to Stage school and I want
to
yeah I'm happy to leave everything and
go and do that and
um yeah so I I really every opportunity
was like
um yeah I guess that little part that
you said like I've got nothing to lose
it was like yeah
on the other side of this could be
absolutely everything so I I have to do
it
I read this book I say red I watched the
summary on YouTube
but I'll just say it sounds more
impressive I read this book called The
Body holds the score then if you ever
heard of it and one of the most
fascinating things about it is it talks
about how acting and moving the body in
like yoga have been proven to be the
best forms of um uh antidepressant like
without you know taking ssris or
anything they've been proven to and I
remember thinking acting is a great
antidepressant how is that possible but
what you're saying now Rings it talks
about how it kind of disassociates from
Identity when we Act
um and so what you're saying now seems
to
validate what I read I'd love to read
that because that's like exactly what I
instinctively like discovered
uh like it just happened and I thought
ah like this is what I'm supposed to do
um have you ever figured out why why
acting was a because I I say the word
escapism but it why it was so liberating
for you is it because is it escapism is
it because it disassociates you from
your own identity is it because you can
create this new
there's like two parts of it it was like
how I felt
like within my body like everything
floated away and like the way that it
felt to move my body or the way that it
felt to like contort my voice or like
whatever it just like like that feeling
when you're like can't stop laughing it
was just like
incredible and then there was the way
that it made other people feel and
I guess like with with acting with
dancing it was like it was very it was
very much about the way that it felt and
not necessarily the way that it looked
or like how other people would
experience it but with acting it's like
you get that sort of two-way thing and I
also saw the joy that it would bring
other people and like
I guess like you don't you're like not
disappointing you're like making someone
laugh or you're making someone happy or
you're like and that was like you know
fun and new
yeah I was gonna say Game of Thrones was
a Smash Hit but it feels like a slight
understatement
I feel like smash it is let's yeah it
it huge the fame piece
I've had a smidge of Fame like seven
people know who I am right and sometimes
it can be a little bit difficult so I
can't even you know I can't even imagine
especially with the the sort of
confounding factors of your age
trying to figure out who you are
becoming famous for being a character on
a huge show yeah um
being in your sort of adolescent years
all of these things all at the same time
when you look back and you know you and
you remember you're saying about how
people were like forecasting your
downfall because of all those factors
yeah yeah
that actually the strangest thing about
it
the hardest thing I think was
like needing to articulate
who I was and what I loved the things
that I didn't like and what I had an
opinion on and what like you know
um yeah that I remember at the time
being like oh gosh I really don't know
anything about anything I really need to
know these things I need to you know
and then like you know years later you
go like oh I said that my favorite film
was this and like that's not true and
it's like you don't need to know any of
that stuff no like it's all
um it's all just like a journey right
it's all like there's never like an end
um what advice would you give that
person 13 year old
amazing to be honest with you like I
wish that I'd have just um like trolled
it all a bit more
and like whatever I like
instead of really digging deep and going
oh what is the real just like whatever
you feel that day that's okay and it can
change the next day because that is just
like life
you don't have to be beholden to
anything that you've said or done you
can let it all go and like rip up the
rule book because I hated London moved
back to Manchester and went to New York
and you go actually I'm gonna go back to
London like this is what I'm gonna do
now and it's not going to be like
something that you're like oh I wish I
hadn't done this like you're like no
this is this is what I want now and
that's like
that's just sort of the way it is so I
kind of wish that I'd just like you know
not just like tortured myself to know
like what is the real answer to these
like silly fun questions
um and then been like oh no I've like
portrayed myself all wrong this is not
who I am because it's just it's like
it's like water
would you would you change the timing of
the events that happened in your life if
you if you could
like acting when I was super young
um
the only thing I really feel like we
didn't have a lot growing up but like
I've I've never
you grew up on a continent in a council
house
and
like you know have always had like a
awareness of how hard my mum worked like
raising us giving us everything that you
know she did putting food on the table
um you know but that kind of I I never
I remember like when I was sort of like
18 and a lot of my friends started going
to UNI getting jobs whatever I remember
like there was like I was like I never
even though I know what that struggle
was like growing up like I've never like
struggled to get a job or
um struggle to make rent or anything
like that and I think
not that I would change that of course
like I'm so fortunate but I guess like I
I never want to I never
want to lose sight of like the
perspective of like just how fortunate
that I've been and like just how tone
deaf it is for me to believe that I like
would understand what it's like to
you know to struggle to make rent and
want to be a creative person and not
know whether to get like a sensible job
or to like because I don't know what
that struggle is like at all
um
so yeah I don't know that like I I
sometimes
worry that I'm like alienated in in some
ways because it will happen when I was
so young and like literally from the age
of 12 I've been like sat for life and
that's like very different to how I was
like before that age
is there a mixture of emotions
surrounding that like being set for life
at 12
um as you grow now I've sat here with a
couple of guests who come from like a
council a council estate or grew up in
in very difficult situations and they
often express this kind of I remember
Jack commit doing it expressed this kind
of almost
guilt's a bit of an interesting word but
like why did I I remember Jack saying to
me I can make thousands and thousands of
pounds from just making YouTube videos
and I watched my dad not make the same
amount of money in like a year or
whatever and I could just make it from
one YouTube video and he would go back
and feel he'd meet someone I remember
him saying he met someone in a pub that
was like a cancer doctor
and he's making more than them just sat
at home he anyone who expresses his kind
of like
I don't know guilt or Injustice have you
ever felt that
um definitely like
um
just yeah real like the guilt around
like
allowing yourself to have nice things or
do nice things because you're like able
to
like I felt like when I was a kid
everything stopped happening and all my
problems were going to go away and then
like all my problems didn't go away and
then I was sat for life when I was 12
and I thought all my problems gonna go
away and I was like well this doesn't
it's not like that unless all of my
friends and family are that way too
because like how are we all supposed to
like be okay if the only one person is
okay
and
you know you give people what you can
but you don't see the the pain take that
take the pain away for another person
doesn't take the pain away for yourself
like
and then you realize that like actually
life is something else entirely and like
the biggest problem that a lot of people
face is
making money
and like I'm making enough money to live
and like
support their family
but being able to do those things
isn't in it like the only thing that
like makes you happy like when you take
that problem away
there's sometimes still a very hard
discussion that you have to have with
yourself where it's
like a yeah like a fundamental chat
where you have to
tell yourself that
well I don't know there's a lot of
things
I don't want to take away from the fact
that like having money enables you to
like even be able to comprehend or like
another set of problems yeah yeah like I
know that that in itself is like an
incredibly privileged position to be in
um
uh
but like money won't take the pain away
it will take like the stacking bills or
you know
um or the fear of like losing a house
you know
um it doesn't undo trauma you can't you
can't buy you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah even if you can keep
the heat on and the electricity and feed
yourself there's still there's stuff for
many people another level of trauma
which um money can't seem to solve for
directly
um
the
the post game of thr you know I I
remember sitting here with some one of
the guys from One Direction Liam Payne
and um he talked about how
post One Direction you he has this
identity which is he's a part of a boy
band and then leaving that it can be
quite Troublesome psychologically who
and I think he talked about the same
thing which is like who am I where do I
belong how do I then go and ident like
find out who that person is and start
creating for that and not just being
this this character this you know member
of a boy band that I've that the world
knows before did you ever feel that post
um Game of Thrones
yeah in a way but but I felt like I had
got to a point already within being in
the show that I was like oh I feel like
I'm
like cosplaying as this like person I've
created and I don't think that this
really is who I am
so sort of leaving the show me that I
could leave that as well
um
you know I kind of like wanted to like
say the right thing and do the right
thing and like act like I had everything
figured out and like be a good role
model and you know
and which is all very good things to
want but it's like it was it wasn't like
very authentic it was like just like
trying to be liked I guess right and
then you're like oh I actually you know
I don't want to do things that make
people like happy because like I wanted
things to make me happy and like I want
to you know represent myself the way
that makes me feel most comfortable
um and not like just the way that's most
like palatable or like whatever
and so I I already got to the point
where I was like oh this isn't really me
and I'm like desperate for something to
just like drastically change so as I can
like cut from that and and that's sort
of what happened when the show ended
then also sort of sped up by the
pandemic and being like ins like
solitary
um
so I was kind of like very ready for
that and it wasn't like oh who am I I
was kind of like oh who could I be you
know 21 21 22 years old
how are those years for you so this is
like around the time the show is
concluding yeah included when you're 22.
yes when it came out yeah
um I just didn't really go out a lot and
I
I just felt quite
I just I don't know it was just like it
was like the most successful it was ever
going to be and it was like most people
would like recognize you on the street
and
and like I had just got so like
rehearsed at like oh thank you that's so
nice and I just like everything I said
and felt and did it was just like oh
none of this is it's like
um
I just I felt like very going through
the motions of Life uh it was like yeah
acting again yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
it wasn't
the like the the hardest like most awful
and traumatic like oh it was like
terrible it wasn't it was fine but I
just like I knew that something better
was coming at that age they're 20 years
old how do you feel about yourself
oh I didn't really have a very like good
opinion of like myself and my self-image
it's I forget that I really didn't like
myself that much
um
I don't know I just I just told myself
that I
was like
awful and disgusting and
like unattractive and unkind and
like just like not a a good person and
like unlikable I just told myself that
like every single day and so in ways I
sort of became like that because
um you just like beat yourself into like
a mess you know mind is quite powerful
in that way yeah really powerful mm-hmm
Fern talks to me about this a lot I know
you did have podcasts right yeah yeah I
listened to her chatting about this on
your podcast yeah yeah
do you know the origin of those of those
of that self story like where where it
originates from obviously you have a a
thread that most people don't have which
is the world is giving feedback on you
every day now because you're in the
press and you're a young woman and we
know what that can be a pretty vicious
thing but it do you know the origin of
those self stories I feel like I've I've
felt self-conscious like even before all
of that so it definitely before like
Fame and so it definitely was enhanced
by that but I think it came a lot
earlier
um
and
I'm actually still trying to figure this
out like at the moment with my therapist
we're trying to really Trace that back
and a lot of this like has come a lot of
the discovery has come through
meditation I've been doing a lot of
Transcendental Meditation and like
there's something about going into that
state that like brings up like a little
ticket and I go ah like that's but but I
haven't quite figured out the answer to
this one yet I'll wear it like initially
stems from but I've definitely felt like
embarrassed of myself or ashamed or like
you know thought oh like I'd be playing
at a kid's house and thinking like their
parent thinks that I'm like awful I'm
like the child that all parents don't
want their kids to hang out with like
I've just felt this way about myself and
I was like
you know I wasn't trying to get them to
do like naughty things or anything I
just was like a kid that was just like
but I thought you know I'm I'm like
like I'd go to someone's house and I'd
like my shoes and like maybe they're not
in the right place and I haven't put my
bag in there and this parent is gonna
like not like me or like whatever I I
like felt that like
like self-awareness to that degree where
I've like critiqued and like
beat myself up like since I was very
very small
yeah I don't really know I don't know
where it comes from yet Elena well the
question I I naturally ask is when when
was the first time someone
told you those I mean even the example
of like oh God if I put my shoes in the
wrong place well you know what happens
if they're in in the wrong place and
what's the consequence of my shoes being
in the wrong place because Me growing up
with my shoes were in the wrong place
there's not really a consequence for
that no you know yeah
I don't know
well I have some theories on it
um
but I don't know it can it doesn't
concern just me so I don't know yeah
yeah just like I I think that I've like
um I've witnessed
uh like people just feeling like just
them existing in one spot is like them
just taking up too much room in this
world and I think that I've like just
taken on a piece of that
um where like just living and breathing
like you're too much and like you're
irritating so
but it's not true and if anyone ever
feels like that it's not true
because we can know these things are
objectively not true but it just this is
the thing that really fascinates me is
like how can we have how can we in one
on on one hand know that something is
not true yes and seemingly we're not
able to
completely eradicate that story because
that you know I I used to think
definitely used to believe before doing
this podcast that these stories we
believe there's evidence we have whether
it's wrong true or false about ourselves
I used to believe that there was some
way of just like
erasing it and you just you do this you
do this you tap your head you wiggle
your stomach like that and then it's
gone to therapy twice you do this spin
around and it's gone but no matter like
I don't think I've ever met a guest on
this podcast that has gone through some
kind of traumatic early experience in
their life and has ever erased it ever
people will say they've you know they've
built
new evidence which counteracts it so
that the New Evidence makes the
decisions in their life but it's still
there and traumatic events can make it
flare up
I'm one of like I consider myself to be
one of those people where
I've got to be very aware of of my my
triggers because you know they might
take over the control room once in a
while um
and start calling me shots so
I I feel like
um
I feel like just like experiencing it
all in the moment
is interesting and like not sort of like
predicting that there's like an end to
it
but you go like huh I have been in this
situation before and like last time I
wasn't aware of these triggers and now I
see exactly what's what wants to happen
and I'm not gonna do it
and like there's the piece of your brain
that's like actively making those
decisions and going but then there's the
like
I don't know Consciousness or like you
know the spirit that then observes it
and goes huh
like
what happens next like you're playing a
board game right and like something
happens and then like you're sort of
above it and you go where will this go
next
and and every time that your brain
doesn't manage to do that it's not like
going straight back to that place that
point even though like that's the way
your body's reacting it's like you're
still at this point in the Journey of
life and this is how you're experiencing
it in this moment and like it's not like
oh you failed at like healing because
like there's no end to it it's just
you know in this moment what can you
what can you can what can you learn your
brain has gone back there even though
like previously you've managed to avoid
this or you've managed to sort of like
avoid a trigger or like you know rewire
something but it hasn't this time so
it's like what can we learn from looking
at it this time how do I see it
differently to a time when I would have
like done this before
and it just it keeps going like every
minute is like an opportunity to like
see
where it will go next
um
and it will never be erased because like
it's a vital part of who you are and
like without it like you're you would be
in an entirely different person it's
like what is that film
um Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
he like gets his relationship removed
from his brain basically wait yeah I
haven't no but yeah I've heard about
this thing called the Eraser test which
they do on people which sounds exactly
the same yeah
um
it's important it it gives you it it
gives you you know all of the tools to
make decisions in your life
um if I could give you an eraser
um
would you use it not a single piece
why
because
I feel I think that there's a point in
everyone's life where
they
experience firsthand that life is
extremely unfair
and it can happen at any point
and it's unavoidable I think well I
don't know Melissa maybe isn't
in a few years I might have a different
answer to this question
but
the things I experienced when I was a
child no person should ever experience
at any point in their life
but
it's taught me so much
and
I feel this like
com complex like
a deep emote like these complex Deep
Emotions
um
that are ultimately what I use every
single day as an actor
and
um I can I can I can recall those things
and I'm
I don't know that
I'm grateful for that I'm grateful to
understand
the
deepest pain
and fear and also like the most
liberating joy and freedom
and like maybe you don't have to go
through those awful awful things to feel
that but I did and
you know this
spectrum of emotions that are like
within me
I feel like incredibly
fortunate
for
because I think that that is something
that's different about me
so you you go through that phase after
being 20 you go through quite um
significant what's the word
self-disparaging self-hate
um as I've heard you describe it
you find it hard to to think or say nice
things about yourself
have you overcome that
because when you did that interview with
Lewis you were talking as if it was in
the past yeah I desperately wanted it to
be and I still do I think that
um I've got like a lot better at it
um but you know whenever
whenever
you know I sort of
fall back into
pain or whatever
it always comes back to like this
fundamental feeling that like I'm just
not worth like
any of it like I'm just like not worthy
of like
you know
and that's like
it's like it's hot it's
it's hard to combat that when you're
like well but I'm really really talking
to myself differently and I'm really
trying to like put up boundaries and I'm
trying to really respect myself and like
do you know
um
treat myself with some respect and then
you just like still get to this point
where you're like ah
so that's like difficult and like that
is something that I struggle with and I
have like you know
periods of a long time well that doesn't
happen and then you know periods where
it comes back again
um
but yeah just like keep combating it and
telling myself that it's not true and
that I am like
I'm worthy of
everything in life of of
whatever I want from life
has has
um has anything helped
truly not like you know we say oh this
helped uh here's five tips to help you
[ __ ] [ __ ] we write in our books
and stuff but has anything truly helped
to advance that feeling of worthiness
yeah I
meditation and uh spirituality which are
two things I didn't have a relationship
with for my whole life up until
um 2021
so yeah five minutes ago five minutes
ago yeah
so just last year
um
everything everything really changed
after that point I
you did mushrooms didn't you no
it was it was awesome
Transcendental Meditation
um
uh and and then like a couple of like
very
like surreal life-changing spiritual
experiences just like in day-to-day life
like not high or anything
um that I just like couldn't ignore and
I felt like oh I'm like I'm not alone
like
you know like there's something else
um even on like the hardest days like
there's something here that's like
gonna be there like gonna you know
take care of me
um yeah
and so that's like
easier to then just like keep going you
know
when you were 22 you talked about
um previously having
issues with substance abuse
uh yeah well yeah did you talk about
that or have I just inferred that from
you use the word substance I mean I I
feel like I spoke about this a little
bit on Louis yeah yeah
but like
I don't want to undermine it but
I guess
whom I say like what normal teenagers do
and what normal teenagers don't do
um but like you know I
like party like took a lot of party
drugs and like partied when I was like a
teenager
um and
I was in the position where like I could
buy more but I didn't really do that
you know to a terrible degree
I yeah yeah and but but it was like
definitely something that I was like I
need to stop doing this if I want to
like feel happiness
um
because that's the slippery slope
especially things like very accessible
things like alcohol even yeah you know
I've had people very close to me that
have have become alcoholics because of
you know trauma they've been through and
stuff like that and I do do you drink
now what's your relationship like
without alcohol and stuff no not really
I mean I I don't I'm not like sober
um but I don't I don't really drink like
in the house or like on a weeknight type
thing it's usually like with dinner or
like you know a gig or with friends or
yeah
but yeah a lot of that is like quite um
was quite a welcome like
release I guess it wasn't like something
that I
you're so busy as well I struggled with
if you're filming like 250
filming days per season or per year yeah
I mean the whole production yeah okay
but yeah yeah exactly it was it was it
was like hot it was you know very busy
schedule a lot of sleep needed to do to
get through there I had a few words to
say about one of my sponsors on this
podcast my girlfriend came upstairs
yesterday when I was having a shower and
she said to me that she tried the heel
protein shake which lives on my fridge
over there and she said it's amazing low
calories you get your 20 odd grams of
protein you get your 26 vitamins and
minerals and it's nutritionally complete
in the protein space there's lots of
things but it's hard to find something
that is nice especially when consumed
just with water and that is
nutritionally complete and that has
about 100 calories in total while also
giving you your 20 grams of protein if
you haven't tried the heel protein
product do give it a try The Salted
Caramel one if you put some ice cubes in
it and you put it in a blender and you
try it is as good as pretty much any
milkshake on the market just mixed with
water it's been a game changer for me
because I'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and I'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so this is
where he all fits in my life thank you
heal for making a product that I
actually like The Salted Caramel is my
favorite I've got the banana one here
which is the one my girlfriend likes but
for me salted caramel is the one quick
one as you might know crafted are one of
the sponsors of this podcast and crafted
are a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewelry is
it's super affordable it looks amazing
the pieces hold tremendous meaning and
they are really well made I think I've
worn this piece for almost a year it
hasn't broken hasn't changed color
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 Quid people will
be surprised when they hear that they'll
probably assume that all of my jewelry
is like solid gold and cost thousands
and thousands of pounds but what's the
point when you can achieve the exact
same effect from a piece of jewelry
that's high quality and costs 50 Quid
that's why I buy crafted we before we
start recording we talked a bit about
Reuben yeah
your voice changed when I mentioned Ruby
yeah yeah and you're you're wearing a
shirt that he a t-shirt that he designed
yes created yeah
inspired by these artists called
Jean-Claude and Christo it's dope my
husband and wife who wrapped a bunch of
iconic landmarks and buildings in fabric
so cool yeah it's quite cool it's very
me so
um when I'm not wearing all black to try
and be uh stew Economist on this podcast
um what is how is how is
how has it been going through trying to
figure out romantic love
that's a that was a very difficult thing
for me as I talked about earlier but
how's it been for you what's that
Journey been like
um I think that I I definitely like
resonated when you spoke about
um
like rejecting a lot of like
relationships friendships or whatever
because it's like
cringe or like not real or like whatever
I I feel like I definitely spent a lot
of time doing that and I never really
confronted
um
the the part of myself that
um
I know it was like desperate to love and
be loved but I didn't really know how I
didn't really know what that looked like
or whatever
um
I don't really know how deep to go with
this
I never like had relationships where I
was like mistreated
um but that was mostly because like my
trauma response was like whenever there
was like any hint of like
I don't know conflict I was like I'm out
like
no I don't I seen this one before and
I'm not gonna be Hoodwinked by this but
like the truth is is like they were just
like nice people and I just ran away
like you know and
and cut off like whatever emotions were
there and just like Marie sorry like
it's not really gonna work type thing
um and then
you know with confronted with someone
like Reuben who
um
stop
[Laughter]
um I think that I I met someone who
um whenever I would start doing that and
start going like oh
they he like saw it within me and was
like you see what you're doing like
you're you're like trying to
sabotage yourself again and like you can
do that like I'm not gonna stop you
yeah
that was the first time that like
someone was patient enough
you know even though you're really
trying to push them away
to be like
that's fine like I'm not trying to like
tell you not to but like just observe
what is happening right now and like
you can sleep on it fine like you can
sleep on it for a month if you want to
fine like whatever
and it was the first time that
yeah
I
I realized this pattern that I hadn't
been able to capture like catch before
and um yeah it's been incredible it's
been like four years now and we live
together and
um
I've like never never knew that like
peace and joy and like happiness and
like
like coexisting with another person
could like be this way I never saw this
in my life and like it's just all new
and like
yeah all beautiful
so interesting how sometimes it takes a
certain person to like get over that
wall
you know and it's funny because I feel
the exact same way we try and stop
people getting over the wall because it
feels like self-defense it's ultimately
self-sabotaged but we we try and prevent
them climbing the wall but then if that
person can get in they can go about
writing a new set of evidence you know
we talked about evidence if that wall is
essentially evidence it's like it's it's
a it's a shield built on faulty evidence
from a from another experience if they
get over it they can help us go on the
Journey of making new evidence but it's
it's very difficult to get over and then
eventually something they do can just
back get inside that that last line of
defense and it's good when they do right
because
you can learn how wrong you were about
so many things you believed um
and then you go like wow every single
thing that I've
just like Define myself as like
it can all be
different
and like that's
like real freedom I I think
like yeah just one of those little
pieces
were
yeah everything you
thought you knew about the world just
like
changes you can then be like what else
am I wrong about or like what else
not like even right or wrong it's like
what other ways can I
like experience this like what are the
how else
can
um
yeah like what new sort of like
possibilities are there
for like who I am and what I'm gonna do
who are you
and what are you gonna do
[Laughter]
um I am
a
um
I'm like a kind and sensitive
person and
I
want
uh
and I want to like
I want to like I want other people to
feel happy
like I want to I can't like bring like
make people happy but like I want to
cons I like I'm considerate of like
people around me and like how they might
be feeling or whatever why is that
difficult to say I don't know
I don't know
I don't know if I had to like really
think about it maybe it's like
like um if I if I if that's like really
who I am at my core which like I I
really feel like I'm speaking from that
there's pain there because
why was I made to like feel like I was
such a monster you know
yeah
it's painful because I think like if I
take away all of the things that I
project and like oh like I'm someone who
like speaks their mind and like I don't
care what you think and if I like take
all of that away and I'm like who am I
really
and I actually just like
you know
like someone who's quite sensitive and
like wants to make you know want wants
to be considerate of the people around
them
like why why do you just like keep
putting things in front of you that are
going to stop you from just like being
that when who you truly are isn't a bad
thing like
those aren't bad qualities to have as a
person so why like why
you know
why am I so ashamed of that or like
whatever you know
like why yeah why why am I tripping
myself up to like not be that maybe
because like once that wasn't good
enough right and I'm telling myself like
you know that's not good enough
it seems like it makes sense as an
explanation
yeah I was thinking as you're saying I
was thinking well you know if you've if
at one point you had to be someone else
or you had to be you had to meet
expectations in order to be told that
you were
good enough expectations that were
unmutable you might spend your life
dancing from one expectation to another
just trying to please
the world's expectations and I know you
know now because I've heard you talk
about it that expectations are really
trying to meet social expectations
anyway really are the
slippery slope isn't quite the word but
but it is quite I think slippery
slippers maybe a good phrase to use
because
it's all down from there isn't it once
you start playing that game
it's the self-destructive spiral down to
[Music]
a place that's hard to climb out of
like maybe I don't value just like
like just kindness and can sit like cons
uh consideration in other people
I'm just spitballing on this by the way
yeah so am I yeah what makes you think
you're invaluate other people well
just because I I have this other sort of
theory that I've been like steering for
a while where it's like you
you hate them like you you despise the
most like what you are
or like you're you're the you reject the
most
like
who you are inside that would make sense
if who you were was rejected right
if you were told that who you were is
not a good person and that is a belief
that you have then if you see that in
other people you think well that's not a
good person
because yeah
yeah
I'm just a bit boiling as well but um
you said that you
kindness was a quality that you um in
other people either didn't you thought
you weren't didn't like it yeah maybe
it's something I don't that like value
enough I don't like if I don't think
it's I'm work like well you were told
not to Value right directions in a sense
because you were that and it was real
negatively reinforced yeah
yeah I'm just guessing but yeah
I guess we both of them yeah what what
is success to you if you are if you know
if you look back in 10 years from now
and say I was successful over those last
10 years what would that be
well there's like a lot of like tangible
things that I want to do with my career
um no no no right okay so yeah just like
exactly you
know yeah but like I mean I guess
success would be like
like knowing in my soul that like I just
I deserve any of any of those things or
like
like just uh
um
feeling adequate what is success
well I've I've already said that I don't
feel like it's a destination right
it's like a happening every second
it's not like it can't look I can't
stand on the other side of success and
look back and be like what a look at
that moment it's like what you look back
on it's every like every time you're at
a Crossroads or a decision and like how
what did you choose to do that's all you
can control is like what's happening
right now
like are you going to choose
this path or this path like are you
going to behave one way or another way
are you going to do the things that you
don't like about yourself and continue
to do them or are you gonna like do it
differently and you're gonna like talk
about yourself in a different way like
and that's like it's every second and
and there's no other side to it
um I don't know maybe Enlightenment if
you
if you believe that um
but it's about the
the journey with you're 35 years old you
sat here again yeah and you go
those last 10 years yeah they were a
good 10 years yeah
which I'm sure you will say but if we
sat here you're 35 years old I'm like
I'm dead by then I'm like 75 or
something
I've just turned 30 and I'm like living
a crisis I'll be 40. so
um I love all my 40 year old listeners
thank you subscribe
um but you're 35
um I'm sat here and I'm 40. we're
looking back on the last 10 years and
we're going yeah that was really really
a great 10 years what would have had to
have have happened in your estimation
for that to be true
um
I guess like
um like control oh no control that
sounds like
like I I
um
I guess it would be like looking back at
all of the moments and
you know seeing seeing the the conscious
decisions that were made rather than
just like
acting on impulse right
I guess success would be like that was a
point that was really challenging and
like I feel really proud that I didn't
slip back into that old habit or I
didn't like
you know
I I didn't like just go completely
selfish and think like oh my problems
are the worst in the world like I just
think had a bit of perspective and I
like picked myself up and I I kept going
like I guess that's like I would look
back on those moments and feel like
those decisions like would define those
ten years and I'd be like proud like
proud of of that
um
yeah do you have a do you have a do you
have a sense of mission about you at all
Mission definitely
I mean
the the freedom and
like the The Joy the
I feel through performing
um and I'm I like it's just it's changed
my life right
and like we're at a place where you know
there's a lot of people who
want to like you know make art creative
people who want to
um sustain a lifestyle of like making
art and like you know
um whether that be acting singing you
know writing uh
and now I guess like the mission is like
I I want to build companies or like
um you know work with people and like
kind of continue the ethos of like
um you know pushing creative people to
be able to sort of like sustain a life
of like you know creative work because
I'm like in a very fortunate position
where I do what I love and what
I do also brings me money and
the way that the work makes me feel is
like the best thing ever
and like that those like three things I
think are like a foundational piece of
like being a like a human and like
it's like should not be as hard as it is
for like people to be in that position
and
um I when I when I'm around like down
about like the world and like
like whether it's the government the
environment or like
anything
um
I like kind of Wonder I'm like what if
like more people could do what they love
for a living like would we actually be
in like just in a better place like
not that those things like influence any
of these like poor decisions but
like I see like so much there's a lot of
pain like like there's a lot of pain in
the world and like life causes people a
lot of pain
and I am
yeah I just I feel
um I feel like you know art and like
expression through ART and like
channeling
like creativity
I wonder if that would contribute to
making the world a better place
I want for that to contribute to making
the world a better place
you're a very different person to the
person I watched in all of the previous
interviews
yeah well I didn't I'm still the same
person but I definitely have a different
perspective when I watched um because
you did a few interviews about three
four years ago and in those interviews
um just like I don't know what it was
you were very
very high energy
do you know what I mean like very very
high energy
um you seem to yeah exactly sorry that
yeah yeah yeah you seem to just be very
um
considered and
uh
what's the right word
very considered and a bit more
calm
now then oh now now yeah
yeah I think that that's like exactly
how I feel and like it's so
like it's so exhausting like
performing in that way it's not
fulfilling it's not real
it was like I guess I was that way as
like an escape from
from the the quite like the quiet like I
didn't know what was going to be in
there when I like stopped
like
I think that it's like quite a scary
even though like on the other side of
like self-discovery or like trauma
healing like on the other side of it is
like the answer to all of your problems
like it's it's terrifying it's
terrifying to look inside you because
you've always told yourself that like
you're not good enough and like it's
terrifying because you're worried you're
gonna look inside and be like Oh all of
those things were true but no it's it's
terrifying to be like wait maybe like I
am actually worth like worthy of like a
good life like and maybe I'm like
stopping myself from doing that like
that's
a crime
that's not like and I think I mean it's
like I've said this a lot but it is a
journey
but I think it's it's it's like a scary
thing to start buying off and then once
you start buying off then you start to
realize like how selfish that you've
been and you you don't like yourself for
like a number of reasons
but then you start to
like not other reasons to dislike
yourself but it's like
you just I don't know I feel like I like
this you have one life and like and I've
been spending all of this time like
stopping myself from doing it and like
that's
awful
of myself to do that but it's also to do
that to yourself
it's also just like a waste of all of
that and there's like that other
perspective
um
yeah
but yeah just like stopping and having
that
having that sort of um conversation I
guess like with myself has like it's
changed everything it's changed like
and it's been so much better now
so much better and it's less tiring so
many people don't don't want to go near
that
onion yeah you know they don't want to
they don't want to go near it and it's
funny because I I I I you know sometimes
with my own naivety or my own
um
mindset privilege or because I'm someone
that loves introspection I'm like go and
peel it back go and peel it why won't
you peel it back on let's go to therapy
yeah you know I must be a pretty
difficult friend to have if you don't
want to peel back layers because I only
want to peel back I don't want small
talks so yeah yeah but but I sometimes
encounter people that don't want to peel
back the layers and it's frustrating
because you you see the consequences of
unpeeled back layers everywhere in their
behavior and you think well you just
need to peel back the layers and you'll
find the sauce once you know what the
sauce is then you can go about solving
against it or understanding it um
but yeah I don't know what to say to
people when they don't they don't
I guess it's none of my business and
everyone in their own time
some people maybe will never
start the Journey of understanding
themselves and healing and peeling back
layers yeah sometimes people who you
love and are very very close to and like
you you'll never be able to control that
or or like
force them to or do it for them was
there a catalyst or something that
helped you to take that step and and
start wanting to peel back layers and
understand was there anything that
or was it just the pain of staying the
same was greater than the pain of making
a change
I think like
I had always been searching but I never
I never knew like how to go deeper how
to like yeah okay and I think
um
yeah Reuben
meditation
therapy
the pandemic like well because we were
just at home every single day
like a lot of variables like stopped
shifting so I could track my mood like
more
um
accurately because like there wasn't a
bunch of different things happening each
day but I could see like like I could
see it so I guess like the Stillness you
know
um
but like you have you have to you
you have to you have to choose like what
you want there's Comfort sometimes
within the pain or within like the
um onion
and like you have you have to
choose
whether
got like going going there
it is gonna be like paint like the most
painful thing you ever do but like have
you know every possibility on the other
side or is it just like safer to like
not and like get by
and like it's okay because I'm not
hurting anyone and like I hurt myself a
little bit but like I can deal with it
it's like that's the thing you and it's
like at that sort of a hard decision to
make and there's never a right time and
like it never like happens as fast as
you want it to happen and you just like
have to chew like that ultimately is a
choice that only you can make and you
can't make for other people you can't
like persuade them and you can't like
you just have to choose and you have to
do that multiple times where you go I'm
fixed now and then you're not and so you
have to choose again like am I going to
get back on the horse or am I gonna not
and it yeah it's just
professionally then yeah
yeah oh your face lit up again
I'm like it's I
I it's very liberating to speak this
freely
um in with you in this private setting
but like understanding that it's going
to be public because I I've never really
done that I don't think
um and I'm a bit scared I have to be
honest like I'm quite like concerned a
little bit it's like creeping him yeah
but I really hope that it like
um Can Help the people that it's like
you know
or I don't know well I hope but um yeah
I hope that's okay what is what is the
concern
um
I don't know it's
like the media training part of you
that's like don't say this and also
because like a lot of things that I've
discussed like they do concern other
people and so you know there's that as
well
um because it it just gets yeah I don't
know
but it's it's fine it's fine it's gonna
be okay
were you were you um
were you anxious about coming here today
um
uh yes
but I had prepared well no I just had
I wanted
sometimes I'm anxious because I don't
know where it's going to go and other
times I'm I'm anxious because
um
I I like it's like are you gonna be open
or not or are you going to be honest or
not I guess yeah so that was sort of the
anxious thing where it was like
you know I I went to morning yoga this
morning and I was doing breathing
exercises in the car
um because it's like it's very easy to
slip back into the like
uh yeah yeah
it's like still a part of me it's still
a very very prominent part of me so yeah
why did you want to do that today why
did you why did you want to be um open
today
like there's a piece that's like missing
and like if I try and really talk about
things honestly like I just know that
there's this like massive like hole that
I'm like dancing around the edge of
um
and I don't think that it like
yeah
I don't think that that like helps
anything
so
yeah
I guess like what I what I wanted to
speak about today and like we've got we
have spoken about it and it's like been
a lot more emotional than I
you know anticipated but it always is
right
um
but I I it's like
you know like freedom of expression and
like making art really did change
everything and like
I want other people to to feel that
and like I couldn't talk about that and
without like fully talking about what it
helped me escape from I guess
so yeah it's funny with being an artist
that we um I used to think that our
creating art was exclusive I said this
in our show what we did up and down the
country open with this I say once upon a
time I used to think that art was
exclusively reserved for people that
were like artists if it's in your bio
then you can do it you can paint you can
create you can make music you can dance
but it only fits in your buy and you've
gone to like school for it yeah everyone
else we're all like other things artists
over there everyone else over here and
um it was actually when I left my job as
a CEO that I thought to myself at a
fundamental level if I remove all these
labels that society's given me what am I
and that's when I discovered the art in
me that I'd been suppressed because
society says you're an artist and I'm a
CEO
yeah but we're all artists and that
realization has been so amazing for me
in my mind and my mental health and all
those things
do you think we're all artists I do and
I think that you can there's a lot of
words you can use for that that might
make you know people more comfortable
with you know that as a label but I
think like fundamentally like
since the beginning of time like humans
have like made things and they've just
like got increasingly like complex and
like they maybe they've altered like the
human state in like lots of ways and
like you know the way we think and the
way we behave or whatever but like we've
always made things like at our
fundamental level like we've used tools
and we we've made things
and whether you like see your approach
to life or like your mind is like more
like analytical or something like it's
there's it's still like creation like
you're still creating things
um
and finding like
what you create like very freely and
like being able to do that as much as
possible is like an incredibly
fulfilling thing and it doesn't have to
be like painting or like these very sort
of rudimentary like clear sort of
artists Industries like
I don't know like I I've listened to
like some business podcasts and stuff
and they talk about like sort of like
running a company yeah you can probably
have more insights but like when people
are doing like what they're amazing at
and like other people are doing things
that they're amazing at and like you
don't get people
to do things that like they're very slow
and like don't understand or like don't
like doing or like and that's like how
you can like move very quickly
[Music]
and and so it's like but what about like
the whole world like not that the whole
world is like a company or whatever but
like like what if we could all do what
we're like
that comes effortlessly to us like
yeah and it's not just like a but like a
bunch of people sitting around painting
like it's not that at all if you think
about artists as like that very sort of
like
but if people were like free to create
and to like explore their mind and like
you know Express through through
building through making
um the thing that um people sometimes
struggle with is they will say well I've
got this job and I I can't do that I'm a
you know I gotta go to this building sir
and I gotta put you in I've got to do
this thing and I've got I'm a cleaner so
I've got to do this or I've you know I
work in a supermarket or
um I'm a driver so I can't I can't be an
artist I can't create anything sorry
Maisie
yeah well
and this is what I always want to be
like incredibly
um
I guess like
from that person's perspective yeah I
don't have a clue like what I'm talking
about right and it's like it's all like
very nice like in theory but like get in
the real world and like I understand
that perspective
and that's why I think it's like
a like
like a like a a problem like that's
rooted through like even the way that
like children are like educated like all
the way through to
like the way we see
like our working life span like
but I believe I I understand what you're
saying you're saying wouldn't it be
wonderful if everybody could get to that
place if that was even if it's a you
know and I I I personally think that
um I really would love you know if I
could waive a wand and everyone
listening to this could maybe take one
thing away from this from my my from how
I've received it it's like we don't have
to give up on that dream of creating
just because like I remember working in
call centers I remember doing all of
those things but I would
I would also prioritize as much as I
possibly could
understanding the context I'm in and
everyone's in a different context not
one that I can speak to
that um the way out of that for me was
like owning my my own space of creation
even if that meant home and like playing
a video game where I got to like build a
virtual world or in the case of me it
was I was building this business called
wallpark and it's actually more so now
that I'm like learning to DJ and I'm
like doing these shows I'm writing these
books that I'm like
um no matter how much I get caught up in
my identity of like building businesses
whatever I should always reserve a split
space for like creating if possible and
that is so good for the mind I hope
everyone because I know everyone
listening to this there'll be a guy you
know driving up in a lorry listening to
this right now but he knows he loved
playing the drums and at some point he
told himself that oh I can't do that
that's a silly thing that's a
distraction yeah it's a waste of time
that's the worst one yeah yeah I think
like the the
like snowball of like opportunities that
like or possibilities that it opens up
when you just like
yeah you don't tell yourself no I can't
do that anymore because I don't have
time or I don't have
um you know it's like yeah I'm I have to
do this instead or I have to do this
instead like switching switching like a
little portion of your week over
to like freely creating
um
I I think it can bring incredible things
for people wasted time is a really
interesting concept that I've I think in
the last two weeks of doing this podcast
I start to think a lot about was
actually last night someone said to me
oh we should watch um but they say
Prison Break
and I remember like my brain went that's
a waste of time and then I corrected
myself to them and I didn't say it to
them but I remember going do you know
what nothing is really a waste of time
because if you think about the way
creativity works and how we Source
inspiration from so many random things I
think it's and also if you just if it
relaxing is not a waste of time no but I
think we've been quite conditioned to
see if it's not productive and resulting
in some kind of you know quantitative
Roi it's a waste of time yeah what's
your relationship with
time and empty time and space
well I mean it's changed a lot but I
think like currently
um I I don't
like
I don't try and like control like time
this is taking too long this isn't like
you know this needs to happen now or
like oh I should be doing this but I
haven't
um
I've spent like a lot of my time like
I've spent a lot of my time
uh like it's torching myself over like
whether I spent time in like the most
like
uh
like
useful way or whatever
um
but now
it'll it
feel like we even said something
recently because like we've been talking
about time a lot and like
sort of this discussion of like is it
linear like
and this is kind of like you know quite
like can be quite sort of
hypothetical or whatever uh dense things
about like the history of the universe
and like what we all are and what it all
means
but he said something very interesting
recently where he was like I I feel like
what time can do is like arrange itself
before you
and like he sort of talks about like his
schedule like sometimes in a week like
there's a million meetings and they're
all happening at the same time and it's
like uh like are you gonna go like uh I
need to change everything he was like oh
do you just like Let It Be and then it
magically kind of like this person needs
to do something earlier and this person
needs to do something like later so like
these calls all move and then we need to
cancel because so I've got covered like
he was like it like if I like stress and
try and manipulate my calendar to be
like perfect
one that's really really stressful and
two I don't do that and it sometimes
just like it most of the time just sort
of falls into
into place and so I I've always thought
that was really interesting so in those
times where I was like I I need to be
doing this right now but like I can't do
it I can't focus I can't whatever
I am like the space the the block of
time where I'm supposed to do this is
going to find me
that sounds like I'm like avoiding all
responsibilities no it makes perfect
sense to me
many ways I received that the first one
was just like okay I can't control the
future anyway so there's so much anxiety
surrounding trying to the second thing
is that like
my priorities and what I care about will
end up shaping this all anyway so like
if this ran over by a couple of minutes
and I wanted it to run over that's fine
because I made the conscious decision
that this was my priority versus I don't
know walking my dog or something and so
my priorities my values will hopefully
lead me and then there's loads of things
out of my control which is not for me to
worry about anyway so the future should
be somewhat fluid and accepting that's
not always an easy thing but it's
probably a better way to look at our
time
I want to enjoy the journey so
you're enjoying the journey right yeah
more so now than ever
yeah good
are you uh yeah I'm enjoying the journey
yeah yeah I am I just take every day I
think I've just always just taken every
day as it comes and like some days I do
really [ __ ]
and that's okay
but I can't do anything about it now so
I just try and
to just
as I said earlier like channel that into
like
learnings feedback yeah
being better
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast which you might be aware of
um it's where the last guest writes a
question for the next guest oh cool now
I have okay I haven't okay so they don't
know who they're writing it for
and you will never know who asked it
okay
and I don't get to read it until now
okay this person has a bit of a
interesting handwriting okay mine is
worse I'll say but but um here we go
what's the last decision you made
that went
completely sideways
plus what did you do
to correct it
brackets if you could correct it
was like a lot of a lot of things I'm
thinking of and I don't know like
Okay so
I have been working in Paris recently as
you know
um
and I uh I was diagnosed uh like a year
and a half ago with ADHD and I take
medication every day and I like
prescribe that in the UK and I'm like
working in France so I ran out
um
and like couldn't get any more in time
to like go away
I don't know if this is going to be like
insightful nobody's been sightful at all
um
to correct it I tried to get some sent
over but that like wasn't working for
lots of different reasons
um but I guess like the main thing that
I did
was like stop beating myself up about
like
not like organizing it better so as I
had it because I was already feeling
like terrible
um but
you know torturing yourself over this
and telling yourself oh you could you
could have your medication right now if
you'd have just or if you'd have just
done this then you'd be fine right now
but instead you're gonna struggle like
instead of sort of going down that path
I just was like it's done I can't change
it
like I'm I can't do this like oh like my
my brain is like hitting a wall with
like you know I don't know to-do list or
like whatever
and I had just have to ride it out what
made you want to go and get
checked for ADHD but then even that
assumes you wanted to go get checked
I've been speaking to a psychiatrist for
like a long time so he's known me for
for quite a while
um and we've sort of like yeah between
between him and like therapy that I do
sort of more actively
um
like more regularly yeah
um and he suggested it yeah
yeah and it made sense to you it did
like a lot of the things that I like
have noticed about myself
um
like I always remember my mom being like
yeah but you know I struggle with this
and I struggle with that too like you
know and I think she raised me knowing
all the things that she knew about
herself like in a very particular way
and I got to do a lot of things that
came very naturally to me
um uh and she was sort of forced to do
things like she just you know
and so but it was like funny because he
was sort of telling me all these things
I'm like yeah but my mum does that and
he's good yeah it runs in the family
interesting so um yeah it was quite a it
was quite a interesting thing just for
me and my mum to go through actually
um
yeah like had more perspective on myself
but also like more perspective on on her
too which was kind of cool what is your
relationship with the mum I realize I've
not mentioned her yeah we haven't
um my relationship with my mum is in a
really really good place now
um no I mean she
it's like it has been my whole life
um she
I mean she like kind of gave me the
greatest gift of all and just like
supported whatever it is what I wanted
to do
um
and it kind of led me to like the most
extraordinary places and we did a lot
like together
um
and in more recent years I think I've
like I've well you know grown up but
also sort of like you know been more
more independent and like that is like
adjusted our relationship
um as it does like you know very
naturally
um but it's just been like interesting
for the two of us to navigate that from
from being like quite in ways
codependent you know like she traveled
with me while I was like
between the age of like
like 12 to 16 17 and like those are
usually the years when everyone's like
Mom like you're not cool I don't like
you and like me and my mom were like
thick as thieves and we just like
traveled like travel the world together
like me and her
um uh so we were like very like very
very close and like very like had a you
know and we still are we still have all
those things but it was it's just been
very interesting like you know growing
up and and having
uh
like having parts of my life that that
are like just simply my own and like
parts of my career and struggles with my
career that I get through on my own
because like you know I I that's okay I
can do that now and just like the way
that that's been like strange for us
both I think
was there a point with your relationship
with your mother where you started
having those difficult conversations
about the things you were realizing
about yourself and your past and is
there because I I'm just I'm not that
close to my parents so I've just never
had
um I've never had those conversations
yeah like we
yeah we've definitely had like those
conversations
um
yeah it's like incredibly painful
like
it it yeah I think
there's like so much pain you know that
you have like in your own experience but
like you know you'll
it's yeah it's like
very painful to think about like people
that you love like being in pain as well
or like whatever so
yeah
well Maisie um thank you thank you for
uh thank you for coming here today and
thank you for having this conversation
with me
um I learned so much from you know some
everyone I speak to but
um
it's interesting
You're such I feel like I feel like
you're I feel that you're such a good
human being at your core and it it
almost
um
uh yeah it's difficult for me I feel
like you're such a pure good human being
you know and so I really like feel I
feel like every tear you've cried and I
feel all of your all of your pain as
well
um I've never actually got up and hugged
someone during the conversation but no
you are you're such a beautiful pure
human being and um I'm so deeply hoping
that you um
you get comfortable with that truth too
however long that takes for you because
it is the truth and um because that is
the truth it means that you're so
deserving of so much
more so than I am you're definitely no
you are because you are you are
literally like a within there you are a
complete Ray of joy and sunshine and
love and kindness and all those things
that I'm striving to be even better at
so
um thank you and you know
uh thank you for your honesty because
it's unbelievably difficult and it's
easier not to be but you you won't even
get to see all of the the people that it
serves and helps in so many profound
ways so that's what I want to thank you
for and your suit and it's just
tremendously inspiring we didn't even
get to talk about how hard you've you've
worked um professionally we did a little
bit off off air but um to achieve all
the things you've achieved at such an
unbelievably young age but
um that inspires me um your openness and
honesty inspires me your wisdom inspires
me and you know I'm so excited you're 20
[ __ ] five which is unfair it's like
crazy it's crazy
um crazy that you've done so much and
you're such a beautiful person at such a
young age so thank you Maisie thank you
thank you for having me
um and thank you
um thank you for this incredible podcast
I think
um
you as you have spoken about have a real
range of guests but I think that you
um you approach everyone on like a very
sincere and like
um consistent level and I think that
like you as a person are like very real
and that sort of brings out like a real
openness and in the people that you talk
with but you also like
clarify at every sort of Point any part
that you don't understand which not only
makes it helps you understand but it
brings like the audience in in a way
that like a lot of other people don't
whether because like they don't want to
ask questions because they don't want to
look like they don't know or whatever
like you you
are like very authentic
um and like
it's incredibly calming to be around
um so thank you
huge compliment thanks Maisie
[Music]